[Musik]
die usa
aber für meine von treskow überzeichnet
dass irgend einen privatjet werden sich
freuen dass ich nicht ertragen familien
sein
flüge hingezogen können und das st
ports co
petra wieder am start zu haben
[Musik]
wie schafft man es von ganz unten nach
ganz oben und was macht man wenn man
oben angekommen ist
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
guido friedens modegeschäfte einsteigen
und pastor eine ladenkette in schieflage
übernehmen verhandelt wird in hamburg
das risiko
grundsätzlich gehört das dazu
nur die risiken zu sagen das ist wichtig
dass ich mich riesig dass überhaupt für
sie an kontrolle für eine festlegung
risikofreudig oder wenig muss immer
wichtig dass ich sehr gut führen oder
das ist wichtig aber ich versuche
natürlich schon oder das kurz geschäfts
machen ist riesig und faktoren den
zusatz für das kostet viel energie
gespart vor allem wenn es um größere
beträge um wie viel geld es gilt bleibt
geheim
klar ist wenige monate nach diesen
aufnahmen ist der deal perfekt und der
turnaround eingeleitet flures imperium
wächst und wächst
er hat das aus dem nichts zu einem
vermögen von mehreren hundert millionen
franken gebracht
eine steile karriere bisher ohne knick
juli ist meistens im laufschritt
unterwegs und wir einen für ein paar
tage mit von termin zu termin von erfolg
zu erfolg
[Musik]
das tableau reduzieren
ich finde ich spüre dass er einfach über
die zwei punkte und meinem ich habe
nicht viel falsch machen als einfach
denn die stiege ben ali nicht wenn die
stiege die aber nicht viel falsch machen
so einfach wäre folglich wie sie aber
offensichtlich nicht der fall
es geht sehr erfolgreich mit dem urteil
dass ich sicher so verschaffte
aber ich will jetzt nicht das jetzt als
großes talent das würde ich jetzt
gesehen
das ist nicht das größte dollar
juli war ein schulversager besonders
schlecht war er im rechnen besonders gut
ist der unter anderem bei
immobilienspekulationen womit er mit
anfang 20 mit geliehenem geld anfing zb
in der zürcher innenstadt
also das wäre eigentlich
dann berief wo man im bereich bad xwb
eigentlich mehrere gebäude der ziele der
straße bedroht hat schloss sieht wo die
objekte übernommen worden sind haben sie
doch investieren um die vier millionen
ins gebäude schätzt 21 beraten
eingestiegen ist ruhe in den 90er jahren
mit dem in der immobilienkrise als alle
verkaufen wollten kaufte er und merkte
bald wie schwer es war winter zu finden
sie müssen sich das poster wenn sie
inserat machen und niemanden raus und
soooo schlecht und sie haben sich
einfach ein druck spüre sie natürlich
und gespürt
sie spüren dass sich ich bin einfach
einer website wo ist eigentlich alles
egal
unbedingt oder fahrlässig finden hatte
lacht nein
kann ich nie
also eher wenig emotional bin dann schon
eher aber im rationeller schafft ich das
gefühl so rationalen berufen ersten
emotionaler deutlich dass eventuell um
seelisch gesprochen wird eine
schwierigkeit das kann jetzt bereiten
der immobilienmarkt erholte sich und
flori machte ein vermögen er investierte
weiter stets antizyklisch und wurde im
reichen profitieren
irgendwann einmal
spielberg
fluri hat nicht nur viel ergibt auch
viel viel zeit und viel geld flankiert
von vertretern von für hockey einer bern
robin firma weiter der für die
wiedergutmachungs initiative ehemalige
heim und verdient kinder die meisten
bereits hoch betagt sollen eine
entschädigung erhalten
ein wettlauf gegen die zeit
[Musik]
das ist einfach mehr inklusion geht oder
ob er nachher betroffen es war gestartet
das spüre ich leben
ein dynamischer geschäftsmann findet
sich plötzlich in der berner realpolitik
wieder ein kulturschock
eine idee ist und der richtigen weise
ich durchs ziel und das 60 den boden
natürlich lässt sich als kunststoff
rezept einfach nicht flori kann
naja
wie kein zweiter
[Musik]
denn auch in der not noch wie der flug
aus dem sport machen
unterschiede gewaltig sympathischer
probieren sich die einzelne personen im
konzern
über katar mit und erhält dann ich ja
zwh
wir bieten
ja genau
keinen sinn machen
wir sägen das zeichen setzen
zurück
wir haben ja richtig beraten
inzwischen hat fluri für seine
initiative vertreter aus allen großen
parteien ins boot geholt und die nötigen
100.000 unterschriften werden schon bald
zusammen sein
fluri will spuren hinterlassen auch in
der schweizer verfassung aus einer sehr
geholfen hat die welt ein stück besser
zu machen
allerdings
so einfach ist das
das war der punkt dann wirklich losgehen
für diese leute sagt fluri die
unterschriften ehemalige heim und
verdient kinder mit denen er sich
regelmäßig trifft dass er sich gerade
für sie engagiert ist kein zufall
er ist einer von ihnen juli ist der
uneheliche sohn einer 17-jährigen
serviertochter die kurz nach seiner
geburt an schizophrenie erkrankte und
mit ihm gefordert war
seine kindheit war geprägt von fremd und
heim platzierungen
das heim im solothurnischen mümliswil in
dem er einst platziert war der
inzwischen gekauft und zu einer
gedenkstätte umgebaut ein mahnmal für
geschehenes unrecht das nicht vergessen
gehen soll
was vor übergriffen zieht ein konkretes
nicht so toll geschlagen wurde
ja das ist eigentlich eine gewaltige
news aktuell bezieht hat man auch noch
hinter gerade schließlich war sie die
beste ist jetzt genauso aber diese ist
deutlich besser als katrin rauschten im
original sehr miriam off erzählt dass es
so viele dinge sagen du bist nicht durch
rauschen industrie ist deshalb bis wo
sie ja keine das ganze ja es ist jetzt
meine gefühle wenn man sich im hochbau
journal wenn ich ihnen etwas kraft
bestätigen opferrolle
das habe ich ihnen immer gesagt das
kraut minute die umfahrung aber sie ist
so andere spürt man einfach oder ein
taugenichts du bestimmt war der als
tackle saniert ist oder dass das spürt
man natürlich dass das merkt man auf
eine art wenn man nach liter anonymität
den ist sehr gut aus wenn man nicht
seine musik sehr schwach spürt man das
natürlich hoffen dass irgendwo ein ja
separat das unglück die person
was löst das sind ja es ist einfach als
grundproblem ist wo immer die allem aber
im bezirks lampen sozialverhalten in
china selbst schützen das war
gewachsenen abstand führende sie philipp
problemen das nicht vorhanden ist oder
also man sich das entwickelt wenn das
nicht dann hat man natürlich nicht ist
für unser land verschlagen
das freut mich hallo hier
eine multimediale endlosschleife hält
erinnerungen an eine zeit der
körperlichen und seelischen
erniedrigungen woche aber das ist eine
andere
[Gelächter]
es dauerte lange bis er mit seiner
vergangenheit frieden schließen konnte
zentral sei der glaube gewesen sagt
fluri heute
ich bin der weg und das licht dass ich
so einen sondereinsatz formiert um ihre
zugfahrt durch mir durch mich
mittlerweile gibt es nicht nur licht
sondern auch blitzlicht investor fluri
hat vor zwei jahren die marke miss
schweiz gekauft und wurde damit
plötzlich national bekannt einmal mehr
investiert eher antizyklisch und hat
erfolg damit nur wie passt das ins
gesamtbild der marke nebst der glamour
welt zu mehr sehen sprich wohltätigkeit
zu verhelfen war nebst der
stabilisierung nach dem weggang der
schweizer fernsehens die eigentliche
herausforderung für mich
krone mit herz heißt das neue motto aus
der schweiz soll eine art meets charity
werten die geld sammelt für thierry
carrel der da für kranke kinder herzen
operieren wird
die grundproblematik gestorben
dass er das müsse das frauenbild
transportiert wo primär sache besteht
sie sind jung und sozusagen sehr gut ist
und dass das junge frauen aber wohl
unter druck setzen natürlich haben wir
das praktische schönheitsbild basten ist
so etwas jetzt haben wir doch ein strahl
ist auf der persönlichkeit und ihr
umfeld sie berühmt mit filmen einfach
herzlichkeit krones und ihre
repräsentanten und nach alle für die
stiftung
noch immer ist das rohr und wenn die
seitenelemente bei der wahl gestern
abend auf dem bundesplatz gab es dann
zum einen ambitionierte junge damen mit
modelmaßen leichtbekleidet definieren
und zum anderen eine persönlichkeit wie
thierry carrel der jeden tag leben
rettet und einen scheck über 250000
franken entgegennehmen durfte
am ende machte die waadtländerin letizia
barino das rennen maße 85 60 89
medizinstudentin kocht gerne
es interessiere sich hoffentlich fällt
er aus er sich nicht nur es ist wohl
erwarten eu wiederum bestand aus also in
kräne produkt auf zurückstellung
interessieren sich dafür
ich sage was in düsseldorf als mittel
zum zweck nutzen die aufmerksamkeit und
mit charity oder weniger bezug das ist
machbar
die botschafterin hoffen dass die stadt
und die aufmerksamkeit bei große stelle
des dauer fluri engagiert sich schon
seit jahren karitativ normalerweise weit
weg von medialer aufmerksamkeit 30
prozent seiner gewinne fließen in die
kita fluri stiftung davon profitieren
jedes jahr etliche kinder kinder wie
amanda aus brasilien sie hat einen
hirntumor und wird in einem luzern
privatspital operiert fluri stiftung
zahlt sowohl den eingeflogenen star
chirurgen als auch die spitalkosten
insgesamt rund 50.000 franken
[Musik]
bereits in wenigen stunden wird amanda
wieder aufgewacht und alles gut gegangen
sein wie es bei flug selber heraus kommt
ist indes offen
er hat seit 2005 auch einen hirntumor
einen gutartigen wie der sich entwickelt
ist unklar
die ansparung total sinne wurde ich mir
da gedanken machen das ist der punkt wo
ich alles machen die projekt die
ziellinie harnik erreichen
und vorher mal statt das ist so
als verständlich habe ich mir ins tor
dass ich ihnen die warten tätig vorlage
der hengst das ist so
[Musik]
eine von flures residenzen eine tür mit
300 meter private vom vierwaldstättersee
er sei ein familienmensch sagt fluri
einer der geborgenheit brauche was ist
ihnen wichtig mich interessiert was ist
mir wichtig ist mir wichtig mit dem
sinnigen berühre ganz entscheidend
glaubt spiele ein element dazu gehört
also wichtig dass man mit er sei kein
strenger papa sagen seine kinder aber
pfluger durchaus auch eine harte seite
frauen im umgang mit sich selber
[Musik]
die disziplin der sozialwerke die
brauche ich sehr starke spielerin der
fahnen an den trikots der paralyse das
ist so oder blutig aber nicht stärkere
instabilität im inneren eines anderen
einfach alle geschichtlich bedingt das
spielt natürlich positioniert
natürlich das lena ja das ist so
bis zum letzten harten so bis der
rechner kann sich so produzieren ich
hoffe es
das sind wahnsinnige ausstrahlung und ja
das ist es
ich habe eine super
heute ist richtfest flut zurück ins
solothurnische matzendorf war geboren
und aufgewachsen ist und spendiert für
zehn millionen eine neue dorfbeiz und
einen neuen dorfladen
da kann ihn ehren bodenheimer von
bridgestone ein ganzes stück
diese sind dann halten der arbeitsgruppe
noch nicht wieder da wo sie betrachten
sondern der damals gut machen
ich bin in einem krieg
djokovic los wie schnell ist der herr
phänomen das von regierung und banken
zurückgewinnen um so stolz auf sie und
ihnen sehr dankbar
endlich lohnt ganz offiziell von einer
regierungsrätin doch im low bahn nehmen
ist fluri noch nicht so gut daran muss
er noch arbeiten
[Applaus]
[Musik]